new studio bro dude they like that
cheers loving the chairs by far better
than the other one get your dick yeah
dude I want to I kind of want to dick I
want to rub might want to rub my piece
on the mop you're nuts on the new big
baggy chains they feel good in my hand I
feel like you're not you know I feel
like no they feel like your nutsack nope
nope they don't they don't feel like my
not sex is Barnacle II and and wrinkled
these feel like somebody a nice tight
ass they feel like just in a house you
know what do you feel like some titties
yeah sometimes you just grab on you go
let me need those those cheeks like
dough oh they do feel like right uh-huh
man and I like the way it feels on my
palm now the studio is not completely
dunking yeah we got a new sign coming up
back here a new tea fat case signed yeah
Jeunesse put up all the artwork I'm a
slap gym space for not put enough
earlier I wish there's room maybe over
here for a little Jimmy's over there do
a rolling cutting station Fox station
got electrolytes get ourselves a sex
swing [ __ ] station a [ __ ] station so we
got a what's in the [ __ ] station we got
a sex swing little boy we got a little
popsicle stand just just get our mouths
wet and and cold just in case somebody
likes wet and cold on their on their
nether regions right right maybe an Icee
machine little ice machine whatever just
to keep them out now also need a coffee
machine so we can keep the mouth warm
some people like the mouth do you want
to hit up black rifle to get a nice
coffee machine that's a good idea so we
got that and then get more room what's
that sibian the sibian where you get
we're at Fox you mean it [ __ ] you yeah
you want to get one of those for your
butt your man your man no we should make
a glory hole and just suck off the staff
no this always a way to do I'll drill a
hole inside the wall yeah and then
you're gonna suck hold on don't say that
because I'm not the only one I'm honest
the cruel I don't know any of the guys
though that you like that don't do it
dogs come out I'll tell you why don't we
just have a make it cheap
there's a sybian there's a sybian but
let's make it cheap get a get a [ __ ]
plywood sheet of wood and just have a
hole in it and guys can just walk behind
it and just stood on the street yeah
just so you want to be in the middle of
the show and you see
the hard dick come through the hole and
I might be you're okay and also do you
have to hurry up hurry up you want a
cold or hot and I have to take a sip of
coffee or abuse [ __ ] videos sure
have they're always getting sucked off
then you know he's got the buskin you
hear that's how they give a head thought
that about the bus I didn't know that
oh yeah I get when they're going than
you hear oh it's polite to knock so it's
polite to not let just let the girl know
here comes the flood to come in so I
want to stop gonna knock the floods that
come if you hear get your mouth ready
and so we'll have a you can just pop off
there's smelly kid - glory holes you
can't pop off pop off Sunday surprise ya
know Oh girls don't like that man
ah well here comes here comes the baby
batter
now listen have you ever heard like you
know there's things on like Craigslist
Oh glory holes like open from 10 a.m. to
1 p.m. come on by and give them a dress
why you know it could be a sting
operation I'm not sick and when you're
in a hole there you don't know whose
mouth [ __ ] out of your mind okay put
your dick in this wall so you see oh my
god dicks
you know I saw them in the ad I'm sure
it's safe let me put my dick and balls
in this hole dude people are freaked God
I don't know yes turn on this station
well we can you do a glory hole for you
what's up why do you keep saying you
suck them no sucker I'm not a sucker
suck I'm not you join Chicago how was
the Joseph's wedding Joseph so I can
make it I love you you also it seemed to
me how about this again
you can think I'm exaggerating 52 years
old best speech best wedding day best
speech I've ever heard he's a pal Joe
Joseph Azim no [ __ ] no I'm no script
the dude speaks from his heart and you
know what I thought I looked at him and
I went I went like this I'm sad about
him and you you would agree with me I
think the most authentic honest pure
human being I've ever met he's a cop all
[ __ ] aside is the best he's a
beautiful he knows exactly who he is and
that that has a great power to make by
the way good - oh happy there
oh yeah did you know about it I did it
oh no he won't tell you know his thing
now I knew he's going through it but
dink complain
asking me how I did here you drive into
town picks you up takes you a restaurant
nobody better he has issues going on
with his back or whatever nobody better
never seen him down no no that dude
never has talked negative either he
knows exactly who he is he is the the
purest person I've ever met in that
sense oh and by the way he's a rare dude
a guy who will get make everybody around
him better
yeah and then and then you think maybe
he's a baby maybe he's a beta the dudes
are completely that's an alpha male that
dude is that dude is just don't [ __ ]
around
don't don't think he's a pushover in any
way I don't think he was thinking is a
pushing yeah he's a great function he's
a great cop too he had his boys San
Francisco's finest all all Rocko
[ __ ] yeah good guys reception
their mom was the best and then food
shows Italian and Afghani and he has he
had his cousin's the Afghan mafia his
cousin's just a bunch of the back I
looked at this table full of bloods
wolves [ __ ] wolves in the best way
great guys great guys yeah it's a
beautiful place
amazing food amazing mama is MSHA mom
azim was there
grandma x'mas their sister azim was
there hakuna did the mama do mamas no no
no because we were in Chicago and it was
it was it was filet mignon it was really
good food
I had a taco bar later on there was an
after-party at the taco bar afterwards
okay afterwards after wedding cake
everybody broke off we had glow sticks
and there was a there was a disco oh it
kept going no till about 5:00 in the
morning
yep I did all the drugs nothin no drugs
no drugs but a mr. Luke Rockhold was
there so you take a picture of them uh
tits and a SATCOM tits and ass cuz he's
he's been lifting weights now he fights
next week he fights next weeks when I'm
sorry fight this Saturday that's right
so Luke couldn't drink had to go to bed
he's doing that he's in training camp
but yeah he was walking around with he's
walking I was very tight because we had
it we've all had to get the same tuxedos
tuck they don't make tuxedos for a tail
piece in a chest like that oh yeah it
custom yeah it tailor some old ladies
Halen some ladies let's get a tailor
right I got
think I tell her nothing and I was
looking good well I wish I had a picture
and I do have some pictures I'm posting
anything you got bring up Tariq I seen
ya I didn't bring up Tarly I see nice of
you
well we have two buddies wedding tent
post pic we have some pictures but you
late now dude then I want to show you
away what he put down I'm really funny
on the first run over here immigrants
and refugees
that's where Tariq and I were bring that
up target our we were standing there
like this and he said look at he goes
big thank you to Bryan count for hosting
a welcome immigrants or refugees
cocktail hour party in Chicago for yo-yo
and mix wedding this weekend
I haven't felt at home since I was 2 he
greeted all 400 guests and miss him that
posture and in 3 different languages
with zero eye contact you guys a man
hashtag character hashtag worldly
hashtag not racist it was good man so we
had a good time it was a laugh a minute
man it was ridiculous looks nice dude
wish I could have made it you know man
you were miss my friend you were missed
but we had fun we had good times Jake
Shields was there love Jake al heat
how's he doing he's a great guy he's
just awesome there's you and there's me
and mr. handsome the most handsome man
to fight in the UFC certainly is
certainly is we were we were hanging out
and having dinner least you're brave
Friday what were saying though come on
dude it looks good no all right but you
don't look like his dad at oh I'll say
that dude we're the same rage there um
but he's never looked more like a Ralph
Lauren model the next thing I know I
know I know you see him yeah I got [ __ ]
there's another picture I have where you
see them all lined up those bees but he
was sitting there with his tuxedos what
is that picture of us where
scroll up to the far right look at your
[ __ ] eye that's where you're holding
me you're trying to squeeze me and I'm
like ah attention branch op captures the
Roswell alien look like a [ __ ] alien
there oh my god that's always before ah
no it took that picture
it's alludes I know you were squeezing
me but you were being nice where's that
uh that was at The Comedy Store that's
right
dude I had a guy at Brea come up to me
works for a company that rhymes with
masa and he and he you know he told me
about the alien stuff from his line of
work yeah again rhymes with masa yeah
and he works for them sure
listen if his line of work he said
aliens do exist good of course they do
but they've never made contact with her
I believe I'm also said that guy's full
of [ __ ] of course and I want to say this
and thank you for that because um but
also don't I me and quit sending me
alien footage oh I know I know listen
all of you
all of you who believe this I believe
that extraterrestrials exist it would
have to they have to exist because the
universe is so big right but here's the
thing that guy I listened that [ __ ]
podcast
you kept I want my [ __ ] I want my
money and my time back you didn't pay
pay Joe
don't put that guy on is that guy's
little research been telling that same
story he's a [ __ ] liar and if you
believe that guy or any of this [ __ ]
about Roswell that we have UFO eat a red
dick oh we don't you two cream to eat
off you need a green alien dick either
green beer all the green alien dicks no
there's no truth you [ __ ] flying
saucer believe in PB here's the other
thing you [ __ ] another guy that works
for coming rhymes with Raza and yeah
wrath rasa with Ryan he was saying that
guy there's no knowledge of the ecology
went to any what appears for college
thank you
and also the description now this is
this guy he's a lion this guy works were
coming rhymes with rasa he was saying
that that guy a lot of stuff he was
describing is actually from a movie they
can look up haha that's from the
eighties I love it
he's crazy I when I listen to juggle
migraines he did have much getting
migraines do have migraine shaking my
grants he was gonna pick migraines and
what I realized I was like oh this guy
he's actually batshit crazy
not only that he's a nerd who found a
way to get a little bit of notoriety and
people surround them and it gives him
faint up on it I got him late what's
that you're not buying it oh no oh what
the crazy guy the crazy guy nameless
laser on on Lazar Lazar gives you a bomb
laser the crate crazy Lazar on
by Rogen nah it's I can't wait well I
can't wait for the next bike companion
it's all a [ __ ] lie it's all a lie
yeah it's all a lie I can see that I see
both sides no no no huh what there's no
no both sides no no there's only one
side and if you believe there's another
side full of [ __ ] eat our [ __ ] green
dick dick okay
eat it stop sending me you all of you
get don't send me any [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ] well got secret government
agencies get make contact you eat a red
dick too and a green deck no good all
this is okay I got a glory hole thing
get over here I'll suck you suck
no I meant you what's your green dick
through the hole get over here you are
sure who's a lady who's an alien what
seasoning on your dirt you squirt that
alien goose in his mouth who oh whatever
the other point is we are execs did you
watch the the laser thing I saw part of
it were you buying it or no so annoyed
means I dug the problem is the the
documentarian who was there he's
completely that was also well hey Rogan
and hey Joe the guy who doesn't suffer
at all same guy who doesn't suffer fools
at all Stig only why would you give that
guy some time he just likes it though
Joe just likes it he doesn't care look
at interesting
it is interesting no it was entertaining
show yeah it was good fiction but what's
even good fiction it's all six million
viewers oh god people are into it yeah I
know well it would be amazing if we if
when you're covering that show poor guy
you know what you know what I hate say
it's Bob lasers an infant that's what's
going on in a [ __ ] infant's convinced
you're all infants UFO hoaxster but I
think it's great it's actually fun just
don't you know don't take it seriously
it's fine people thought you and I were
really mad at each other no never even
if we are mad at each other it doesn't
matter no you find kids not get in
because I believe in aliens and Brian's
a government show yeah let's not the
help this thing ends and I said I'd sent
Brennan in Texaco hey this [ __ ] guy
all the [ __ ] I want listen and you go
you're a government shield oh my god it
was when you do betray government
secrets of there are there are military
courts that you go to jail you know yeah
you should know you have to get prison
yeah they're guys that hunt you down
yeah you know I had plenty of those guys
call me and text me - they were like I
mean hit me up on DM so like hey dude
just so you know I work for a television
tizzy
it's my job to hunt those guys down if
they search kitchen it doesn't work
there's a whole system and then when
they ask him yeah listen gun to my head
have aliens touchdown Earth I would say
yes do we have any proof no but I bet
they checked that was like yeah as if
you guys are [ __ ] crazy where I
there's a kill each other there's war
it's gotta be there's gotta be extra
Trevor they claim we don't know it yeah
Bob lazer work on the UFOs probably not
hey you know what though the government
the military has secret weaponry that we
don't know about that some might even
look like like a UFOs look I mean look
at the stealth bomber the stealth bomber
bring that up definitely look like it's
a giant blob but but it but it fades
radar they have new ones now because if
they look different that they have where
they have weaponry that they're working
on that is so hot top secret that I'm
sure maybe is in places like area 51 by
the way that [ __ ] there that's the new
one that's a little Bob laser looks like
an alien yeah look at that thing come on
tell me that doesn't look like a
spaceship nothing looks [ __ ] now
guarantee the US government has weaponry
that looks like it's alien technology
and probably behaves like it they're
working on [ __ ] that makes you like they
have stuff that makes it look invisible
it goes crazy by the time technology and
the even though I think Obama said by
the time technology comes to the masses
yeah the White House the government's
been working out for four to six years
yeah yeah by the time we get it they're
like they've already tried it out I mean
it yeah oh yeah there's a lot of that
stuff Charice you bought laser though
there's a lot of secret technology
because we keep it secret we don't want
other countries to have it mmm no doubt
look at that [ __ ] thing
look at me look at Sam damn good luck
fighting the things US military Jesus I
mean come on yeah I just watched you
know just mention Bob laser and then
that podcast blew up poor Jo koy was
part of that he got caught up in the
yet Kasich and a friendly fire he got
him caught him me but then he hit me up
he's a great dude I loved that I loved
Yokoi he's the best I love him so whilst
you do the shout out to get Brea crushed
it over at breath head brave Rios fun
not not close my friend not close in
that drink club though that traffic
I'm fart you not goes you go to all
these clubs like it it management I best
I've seen dude I bet best I've seen and
they redid it top to this year
hilarities in Cleveland brain improv wow
it's so good what about Miami
Miami's get to yeah Miami's good yeah
but that's such a good tight does it
right Jim Bray does it friggin Rob's
you've got some [ __ ] going on right now
I like him better because what happened
was the improv were thinking about
joining up with Live Nation and doing
this big corporate play we didn't work
you know their last beam I'm sorry they
own levity yeah but they're back to
being smaller clubs owned by people you
know as opposed these giant corporate
brands really well if the only issues I
mean if there's uber chopped would be a
[ __ ] peaches o delight dudes wish I
had the money to laughing no I wish I
had the money got the Jay job Saturday I
go you ready to go yes oh I would love
that's a long two and a half hours down
there two and a half hours on Thursday
two hours and change on Friday Saturday
the fast we did was our forty Thomas
worth leaving it to no even then like we
there's nothing down there feel how I'm
forty if you left that to like there's
no it's not a quick it's if we don't
have the infrastructure need something
miles California doesn't have the
infrastructure trained for it just
doesn't have the infrastructure for its
population and it's only getting worse
Thank You Sacramento and you shitty
politicians I mean sattva
California's politics has really come
home to roost
well it's not gonna be I but I don't
believe the Inland Empire I don't
believe Los Angeles and it's greater
outer lying areas is going to be a very
fun place to live in the next 20 miles I
worry about it like homelessness I'm
gonna sit through the roof
you know Brea is considered Orange
County yeah yes I didn't know that yeah
strange yep
it's a it's a great area down there but
the traffic it's it's kind of
unmanageable mmm this and all all around
that area it's getting worse and worse
and worse out there you said they don't
have the infrastructure that's why let's
say on a map or in it was just - yeah
it's too busy yeah you're out you're the
kid oh yeah yeah you're out great I do
anything for the fourth of July dude I
don't know what are you doing
I think about going to San Diego taking
my son to SeaWorld again dad I feel like
that might be a crazy that might be a
mob MMSE world I stay away from I stay
away from everything on times like that
I worry mm that's a firecracker is it
yeah is it weird that I worry about
spree shooting and terrorism I don't
know that's when I worry about it but
but at SeaWorld
see we're all you mean 19 other people
yeah Disneyland different story
yeah you don't think people would be at
SeaWorld not really hmm I'm gonna do the
behind the stage stuff so I said can
like grab a [ __ ] killer whale or
something like that are they still alive
do they still have killer whales there
yeah really got a few I thought they
they just got rid of Shambo okay they
still got killer whales there though we
can do behind the scenes thing where you
like grab turtles and I thinking like
put his hand in the blowhole my kids did
that at the Monterey aquarium this
weekend this past week and they got to
touch you know stingrays and [ __ ] baby
cool you can do that see what some of
the sea otters and I'm not this the
first time I'm not on the road so it
could be fun
see if that pantry hotel it's my
favorite hotel in the world really pen
dream where is that pen drew in San
Diego I can say for my special oh the
best there's one New York tuna yeah the
pantry the pen dream ooh great food
great vibe I remember that huh yeah UK
yeah I met you at the bar for my special
that's right that's right
the pen Dre B people hunt drive down
there do something
yeah would be a lot of fun oh you know
who is it justice wedding was Brad
credit no I'm sorry please tell me Reus
grad Kowski Bruce Jenner no Bruce grad
Kowski quarterback
played 11 years in the NFL hold on you
played that hold on Toledo
yes sir yeah dude yes what right on your
guy great web Adam
just to good use stun yeah real smart
guy smart cool really close with Tariq
and yo suppose I didn't know eyebrows
eyebrows on fleek as the kids would say
you have any brows so tell me about the
plate behind Roethlisberger and just
tell me how when you play anything we do
anything with Roethlisberger he beats
you darts anything any kind of game he's
just moto he was a stud Mankowski was a
stud yeah yeah I got the brows on Becky
yep Italian and polish mostly Italian so
you get their caterpillars though yeah
nice guy though huh great guy smart guy
beautiful wife three kids awesome guy
spent a lot of time with them could I
sat next to him at that at the wedding
but you know good people dude me and my
girl trying to figure out baby needs the
babies come in November why don't we
figure it out right now I said Brian jr.
she wouldn't have him she wouldn't have
it
Brian's a [ __ ] name I'm name let's
come out with it it's [ __ ] - [ __ ] I hate
my name I wouldn't even let you name him
that so let's let's go let's go with
this hold on let me just throw out some
names all right Griff yeah I don't want
him just to work in a junkyard what else
you got
Gus no hold on I just like names like
you know I'm like a little substance
like almost like Tanner all right I feel
like you like you like like strike or
her yeah I do I like those kind of names
I don't know why but I'm striker
okay how about Cain Velasquez how's that
little ass kiss Cain's a good name
Cain's a good name
Kane's get Luke actually I like um you
like Luke Rockhold yeah yeah hold on
I also love Luke it's a good name I love
Luke Rockhold in Jan actually some of
the best people I know Luke Thomas yeah
Rockhold yeah Lou but Cal oh come on
Kelly Kelly for a boy yeah I like Kelly
as a name if it was a girl as your name
her bow ah that's a great bow I got a
name InDesign for my son but I what is
it tell me when I pick I'll tell you off
here because I don't want fans trying me
yeah and I don't
be skewed yeah no but it's cute as [ __ ]
is there anything I always think cuz
here's the thing that's the way dudes
doing locker rooms
whatever you pick you gotta realize
they're gonna give him a nickname so if
his name is you know like my name is
Brent butter Brendan
they called me Brent growing up or did
she call me by my last name job you're
gonna call T tiger T or T T my TIG take
your big dick pic right Bry Bryan son
what huh
picking the names interesting though you
know it is but we got a lot to show you
the list I want the fans chime in cuz I
don't be swayed on a pic but uh is there
anything is there anything to say my
brother Liston of course he's such a
sports nut he said well that reminds me
of this and this reminds me of that city
and I'm like I'm like what are you a
[ __ ] were you [ __ ] do you have
anything on the Schwab you like it it's
not all about sports all the goddamn
time
I'm like you name your kid Jordan magic
and Larry they just all sports legend is
there anything is there anything about
like is our Spanish name is there an
Italian name that's what me my girl you
know what I mean Lorenzo let's name him
like Pablo yeah no no but Lorenzo like
just kidding why like why it's racist
why it's good
there's some cool names yeah we'll see
dude I'm gonna show you the list I don't
be swayed by mâche the list dude how
about just change topics here how about
why don't you name a sound like huh it's
calm honey how do you pronounce it
that'll go over well for him I think it
chicks being like whoa that's hmm and
then insert his name there you go
named Joe Rogan you're just first name
Rogan hey ma'am oof oh for UFO Jesus
Chris they will fall about later
what about Lazo [ __ ] Lazar laws are
shot these are job yeah it's a good idea
how about chin and cat's been all
weekend putting the studio up for us
yeah but that's cuz chin and cat are
awesome and chin said cat actually lifts
more than him she's strong at him and
when he texts now what no [ __ ]
you know two months of the doctor about
his headaches yes and he has a tumor
just gotta yeah God
Palmer boy are we not now it's not a
tumor know that come on do it
the doctor said it's probably just
stress I told you tension headaches yeah
yeah in cradle from staring at your I
mean from working so hard but honestly
not working yep
from sawing bodies so you got to do but
also from your eyes and greens allowed
to get prescription I had that had me
what a long time ago I think chin looks
so much cooler with the glass I did too
you look [ __ ] now dude Chin's a good
looking guy chin I want you to start
working out with me maybe you come to
glove works with me because it's right
down there and we train a little bit
move around a little bit why let me feel
it
it's only roads it's a block away from
here that's super close it's so goes
from here to you Jess I can walk there
practically you've come into Barbara's
up the street I'll be editing the
haircut today let's I meet you later on
later on alright we'll see I'm down yeah
that could be good though but Kat was
carrying more weight than you chin she
could carry a hollow rot away that's not
we got you were built for deadlift and
squat you know I was I was I think back
in the day I probably had a bunch of
enemies like [ __ ] ancestors who would
carry the rice like a spot bar yep they
put the family plant or the bamboo and
then they just [ __ ] go yeah mm-hmm in
another life definitely strong O'Brien
strong over eyes I made for deadlifting
O'Brien that made to bear a lot of
weight pull-ups yeah I can do pull-ups
and stuff but but all Brides not made
for tea like hey we gotta carry this
thing where's Brian's back yeah for you
where I was for your where I was but
this one comic you saw my how this one
kid's athletic who's my feature I know
that's cool man and in front of me goes
into a thousand pole
deaths there she was he into a thousand
pull-ups and the kid goes oh no I can't
no that's definitely a lie
here's no you Tony you do a thousand
guys I tell that to guys who don't know
work out I know you have you've been the
gym so that's I lied
that's a lie staff like I went a
thousand pull-ups that's insane yeah he
was most guys buy it though but I knew
you were coming I knew he's gonna bring
it up and I lied
yeah yes I can't do a thousand
the Tigers but you can do a thousand
dips yes no I can't no I can't
he's again around other comics I can lie
this time I can't
he's a thousand no I had well I remember
the one I just got a flashback of
realizing I was weak as a guy when I was
a young man I was 14 or something or 13
and the kids in my school were lifting
weights there was a weightlifting Club
this was in Saudi Arabia and I was with
two older women don't even remember why
and I remember just feeling like they
were both attractive and these guys were
lifting weights and there were guys I
knew but there were big kids you know
same age yeah
and 13 and 14 was that got weightlifting
club and dude I remember I walked up and
my friend Rami had been lifting it and I
tried to lift it and I couldn't get it
off the bar I couldn't [ __ ] get it
off the bar and I went and of course you
know me I got an ego and I went like
that I went huh
and the woman said hey hey hey no no
don't don't you don't try that you're
not no you're not you're not made for
that like that and she kind of holding
away yeah I remember feeling so weak and
the shame was it worse I was like oh I'm
such a I'm so weak I can't lift that
kind of weight I remember used to
everything was predicated off 225 I can
do 18 I can do 14 I got can do 22 she's
like kind of you can I can only do 20 to
25 he's better than me really silly you
need benching why spend yeah because I
was what all the combine was 220 when
did that happen that started started
right now and I mean yeah high school
well I told you I was five I was in
Arizona and I saw high school kids who
were trying to make it in the d1 like
program stuff there were 18 years old
they were [ __ ] freaks man freaks dude
freaks it was the weirdest thing well
like coop so Cooper played it to play
with the Seahawks for a while he's a
friend of yours event arcs and great guy
coop like we know yeah no neither no
love him great guy but but but he was
talking about how he played for like two
years
you see him you just go oh you're bigger
and strawberries he has only he's a
tight end because
I was 240 wet wet like that's light in
comparison and I was like he's 64 it's
just way bigger than Luke even I was
like Jesus but he was lamenting the fact
he didn't have he didn't have this speed
he didn't have the power because he had
to go up against these crazy defensive
ends sometimes he'd have to play pass
blockage and he was like a bug and he'd
have to block somebody was to 75 to 80
degrees at 4:00 4:00 in the morning
right and he was like oh you have a
problem with he lasted two years yeah
yeah so dude you know I was watching
this planet yeah think I'll plan it the
documentary on the planet and there's an
earth planner yeah crazy seen it the new
one I'm obsessed with it I'm sad you
know i watch it whenever it's on I'm up
stood they showed sea turtles you know a
baby sea turtle has a 1 in 1,000 1,000
one of them [ __ ] Birds pick them off
birds say wait for him to hatch crabs
crabs get him the little one there I'm
gonna how they get the video and now
we're in socks pile you guys does not
[ __ ] her I'll show you guys what they
show the one going I'm like dude he's
gonna make it this stupid [ __ ] crab
grabs him by the [ __ ] tail I know
it's rice yanking him into his house
like that [ __ ] crab it's so I was so
I was one in 1,000 I was in Tahiti I
would just go with a gun shoot the
[ __ ] birds
I was a Devi and I watched them all
hatch and I watched them all run toward
the sea like a mother they all run like
a mother [ __ ] just like this I
watched all of them me and my kids we're
like oh my god and the guy goes one in
1,000 you are gonna survive this they're
so cute there's the birds are like oh
cool we've waited all year for this here
they come and they eat the [ __ ] out of
them yeah look at this although these
ones seemed like to have it an easy easy
going on whoo I want my little turtle
though the thing is Q you look cute
those [ __ ] get eaten alive if
these birds [ __ ] they're in uh how about
1,000 how about those albatross baby
albatrosses and tiger sharks wait have
you seen that where the tiger sharks
wait for the baby albatrosses and just
all I've seen that yep well you know you
know I can fly Oh only this far I'm
gonna land in the water huh [ __ ] you
well you know but Uyghurs sure
also he just grown sea turtles that's
right he smashed their shells that's
right and half turtle soup yeah they
love it yeah yeah oh this little thing
you seen by tiger shirt oh yeah
two tigers on a [ __ ] its own
[ __ ]
we got it's so easy life eats life pros
dude how about about to go
you got Brandon watch this there you go
there you go I'm a baby I'm a little
bird chilling not on my watch [ __ ] I
see her stupid skinny leg yeah
oh he's kind of he's kind of doing the
damn thing though Oh see ya bro
oh that's walking on water baby just one
it got away
wanna cut off yeah dude you liking your
lucky twice that's good he's kind of
just bouncing up oh there that's it yeah
that's the end of that well that's what
you get wow so high here's my thing I
don't care about birds
I know it's mean if I can hate birds I
eat him to be I eat chicken but when you
got that thing's vicious yeah did you
see that girl from Ellen l-m-u
was in Hawaii yes bunch tiger sharks
went we'll check you out here in your
life yeah was it a bunch of my they say
like yeah four or five sharks Oh were
they Tigers that's the word but I
usually Tigers are alone right I would
so I thought you know I think Good
Morning America says tiger sharks when I
went usually target sharks a one-man
mission there yeah that sucks I didn't
know royal Amira mal there y'all killing
Bahamas
what I say does it say what kind of
shark you know what pisses me off
it just says sharks that have to be I
mean could be a bull shark dude I need
detail you [ __ ] me - I need know what
kind of shark how did attack her I need
to know - the scene where three sharks
told you they better in their arms legs
and bollocks over severed her right arm
you know it sounds like reef sharks dude
dude reef sharks are [ __ ] on scroll
up she said my heart is pounding I
cannot believe it I don't know I don't
know how they're gonna go through the
O'Hara okay bummer you can be the shark
though losing your your your daughters
you can't this my favorite the shark
detectors go people are normal food for
sharks I don't like the way they taste
really oh is that so what shark told you
that you [ __ ]
yeah because if they could eat more
humans they definitely would three
sharks while snorkeling Bahamas God I
wish I knew what kind of shark that
sucks I don't expect to lose your child
that way Fox sharks uh do you look you
the worst yeah that's why daddy doesn't
really go in the water a lot you know
cuz always cuz I'm always expecting that
bull shark there's a bunch of bad more
lemon charging higher sharks the lemon
shark can suck my dick the bull shark
and tiger shark nothing road one road
one grabbed it by the fin and let it
take me round a lemon shark yeah either
the [ __ ] we were they weren't
supposed to they weren't they said we're
not supposed to have done that but they
let us do it it was in Tahiti in Bora
Bora man my son punch a lemon shark in
the [ __ ] face as we get the world
just for this girl
yeah lemon shark attacks dude alright
where you know the thing has some teeth
on it they're not a do not represent a
lot like the humans file is ten
unprovoked lemon shark attacks of all
time the [ __ ] in my face dude lemon
sharks and suck it if you were if you
were a fish dude if you're not a bull
shark or great white or tiger suck my
human day yeah
Tigers great whites and bull sharks
gameover gameover get away from a loss
so hammerhead what's up bro yeah go
ahead
they don't do much right what's up bro
come on Brendan go ahead Brandon what
are you saying is that how you found it
off okay like hole in a [ __ ] boy yeah
I put sharks he gets on a stupid mouth
hmm
hammerhead sharks are [ __ ] stupid am
i right only three of the nine species
have ever attacked human yet cuz they
basically can't they're so stupid
they have dumb heads yeah kill them just
it's just kick turtle sushi fin soup
turtle soup to you do anything for the
fourth dude I told you I don't know bro
I'm gonna [ __ ] some sharks up for this
birthday I'm gonna probably just hang
with my babies watch the grill it up can
a firework
so anymore can we well my neighbor has
an arsenal he's got he gets him from you
know those people who flied they drive
to Nevada somewhere you know it and
there's a guy a brother annoying and
it's their one time to shine yeah
they wait all you collect a or tie and
then they're you know it's like you know
Johnson's we got a connection here yeah
oh and you know like that's the spot
yeah it's their one time to shine yeah
it's like the same stupid [ __ ] that
their one times shine is when they put
up all the Christmas lights around their
house yeah and it takes some weeks yeah
and they have a whole [ __ ] Basie
haunted house of Christmas and their
time to shine it's their time Shia it's
your neighbor's time just although my
neighbor is called if I love about my
neighbor is that they have that it's the
everything store and I mean what do you
need what do you want what do you need
you want a lamp he's got it you want a
you want a square basketball he's got
what do you want do you want you want
the singer seal
he's probably got him sure do you want
any gun as if I were anything you want
fireworks it's his one time when he
knows July 4th Kenneth yeah well
apparently I think they got shut down
because it apparently it was so out of
control like his name is Jim blah blah
blah know if I think about it I know
what bleep is last name yeah fire car
neighbor I love my name's firecracker
Jim firecracker Jim and he owns and he
owns have blah blah blah blah company
but if you catch info now this matters
do all right we have to bleep all this
out gives up [ __ ] Williams the guy lives
for fireworks this is fun time to shine
and now you're pranking them shut down
by the Fed throws code block parties
isn't that weird band that's a one-time
don't have the effort well you and I
aren't that way we don't know what's
gonna shine on July 4th yeah don't shoot
guns in the air I think those bullets
come back down yeah they do they're
dangerous yeah really dangerous and you
see it all the time all in the Middle
East they do that a lot
ok those bullets are gonna come down sir
all the homeboys done and and people are
gonna die all the homeboys done
literally deaths by falling
how crazy I remember it wasn't that much
right we looked at it last time 300 to
700 oh now that's per second making kill
it's alright tough to tell you know
that's a lot why you shooting comes in
the air in the first place it's
culturally accepted in the Balkans who'd
say it's me tough to get a straight
number chin okay let's do some current
offense dude hmm under 18 for treated
for random falling bullet injuries how
much 38 of them died Wow Jesus yeah well
don't do it kids don't fire your guns in
the air fire my people all right yes
let's do some current events so as you
guys know Chris D'Elia was on track I
dunno how big this is I didn't see it
dude dude yeah it's so big I love it
do you haven't to play this it's so
[ __ ] cool Chris's in this so hominem
place Chris D'Elia
what Oh M&M place Chris D'Elia then
tweeted out I am NOT Chris D'Elia that's
awesome I mean he's blown up to another
level
it's insane dude I watched all this yeah
you can fast-forward to this that's so
they get the kid off Sandlot right and
then keep going yep keep going keep
going stop right there this is Chris the
dead body he's so good in this he's no
good there's a reason he's getting
jacked to fast forward to where Eminem
plays them which is how amazing it's my
the biggest rep he's so good on the
motor and then then Eminem copies him
look that's Eminem and you tend to be
Chris D'Elia [ __ ]
this is crazy I didn't see that oh my
god it's been out for I don't know since
Friday at that 14 million views
that's incredible how cool is that Wow
he looks good
dude he's getting jacked let's get Josh
for a role yeah oh that's what I'm
saying yeah big-time big-time we're all
- oh yeah he's blown the [ __ ] he's gonna
be the next man
there I said it mmm yeah it was crazy
that might be good for a Batman or
something like that would be hilarious
oh yeah what else you guys got I love
logic - men
it's weird his dad's black wait a minute
Twitter is canceling were they right
canceling but you know the Dali Lama
because he said a female successor
should be attractive yeah so in an
interview [ __ ] weirdos the Dalai Lama
said that if there were to be a female
successor that he thinks she should be
physically attractive because at the end
of the day inner beauty is important but
because we're humans people are more
likely to pay attention if you're easier
on the eyes he's not lying
no but sure it's Twitter really
canceling him no they're just saying
what they're saying it's canceled
culture of we're not gonna watch
yourself or support your things the Dali
Lama you [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
without you don't you wish Twitter was a
human being so you just [ __ ] I mean it's
like but it's it's it's not even it's
this woke far-left horseshit that's not
even real and the Dali Lama isn't woke
enough for you you [ __ ] wackadoodles
wackadoodles I love when they do this
just like Americans
it's like you're so out of control these
people because he's really paying
attention to this well listen Google is
the corporate America is these a lot of
these [ __ ] Facebook these people are
Wilson I hope the predecessor is a girl
with a fat ass some TIG ol bitties and
is just friendly as [ __ ] I wrecked I pay
way more don't [ __ ] merely push it
you guys were listening don't fall for
this horseshit I don't think our
audience would hi-ho in this work
because they're real people
napkins Bank ins but the people play
through my back and Twitter what do you
say would you say be people but the
plumber Americans but not if we're you
see if I could if I could [ __ ] it Dalai
Lama's trying to [ __ ] dudes that's what
this is about
next time on has to be super [ __ ]
yes he's not lying
people are nicer this is the way the
world works
people are nicer people are more
attractive yeah how do you think I get
so much further and comedy than Bryan
what wait why'd know you're wait you
said no more truck Avenue yeah okay
what's it hold on well you mean by this
I get in the sex corner right now you're
about to get put there that's your
punishment your punishment is you're
gonna get it's checking with the suck
quiet straight guy the suck corner we
got ourselves a soft corner we should
have in our yes I came in go ahead and
get sucked off if you want you know we
should have we should have a [ __ ]
yeah plywood with a hole and people have
to stick their dongs through it didn't
we take pictures of yep you have to
guess whose dick it is it's all good
chin I could probably write it from I
just write what he said down
you know I'll draw you a picture Brian
oh yeah be open to you also told one of
my colleagues that that female must be
attractive otherwise it's not much use
yes
can u see my comment upset a lot of
wondering if female dilemma comes and
should be more attractive if favors are
not see a dead face can you see why a
lot of women though found that quite
offensive when you said it so how big is
he looks huge because of some complained
unlike most people he keeps crying as he
goes over like this huge doing
expression but okay I think they
themselves I think
if there's opportunity to us whether
they spend some money for makeup I see
they must do something a lot of women
would say I'd rather have Gronkowski's
eyebrows and it's about who you are
inside isn't it yes I think both real
beauty is inner beauty
that's true but we human being
I think the appearance also important
he's right he's lying off the same place
right now oh you can say the problems
around the blonde with this far left
woke [ __ ] is that they're not honest
they're not honest not worried subjected
to who who it's offensive to who well
what are you talking about it's better
fact you can say no but all of us know
the truth so go [ __ ] yourself this is
the problem with this but if you say
that do it in a corporate boardroom you
get fired
yeah that's cuz people are ugly you get
fired because the other like that's not
fair if you say that - fester as a
politician you get you you you can lose
your livelihood but not when the
professors are hot they're like yeah a
lot of professors aren't getting late -
how about that
I like the Dali lemon you ever you ever
look at the far left like that a lot of
the feminists and stuff see what
happened have moustaches ah they're not
getting laid it's like [ __ ] I can't be
honest most Marxist aren't that
good-looking no never
yeah what us yet gen 8 and I don't want
to compete in the world
so a teenager in Georgia I working at
chick-fil-a actually saved a child by
jumping out of the driveway window and
cutting his seatbelt open cuz he was
choking yeah the kid was kind of like
playing around and the worker heard a
woman screaming the woman was the
child's mother saying oh he's choking
he's choking and I guess the kid somehow
kind of played with wrapped it around
its neck and started to choke Jesus so
there's a short video of him jumping out
of the drive-through window to shout out
to chick-fil-a and the best service the
best service but also the best food they
got voted number one again
easing easing out a billiard hall where
I come from I'd call it an elderly pace
and in the elderly pace the way somebody
with a bad hip don't say jumping dude I
almost ripped my [ __ ] trying to
[ __ ] climb into my house I was
watering my ficus is like I do every
morning and the gate shut and my code
wouldn't work to get back in the gate so
I had to climb over like the fence and
have this big gate dude it was a
nightmare mmm a [ __ ] nightmare
especially at my age it was not easy and
as soon as I'm jumping off my [ __ ]
the the [ __ ] sharp piney thing riding
the choke perhaps praise Allah that it
didn't rip my that's scary cuz my buddy
suspected his girlfriend cheating on him
in New York City guy you know he was a
young man and he was like I'm gonna
climb into her window they've been
dating for six years I'm gonna climb
into her window so there was a tree and
he goes I think I can do this
climbs up the tree because he's so
[ __ ] desperate to find out the truth
he just couldn't live with himself jumps
grabs onto the railing climbs in there
were [ __ ] house finds birth control
pills okay she had been not been taking
them before I guess they had been broken
up and he was like wow she's [ __ ]
somebody then had to get back out and
gonna walk out the front door I couldn't
walk out the front door kitchens there
no because it would be locked so he
decided to go back I would have left out
the front door and then she liked weird
anything yeah well he okay salt well he
didn't and then he got out jumped he
missed and he passed away no I know him
no yeah no he did he catches I guess he
jumped and grabbed and kind of hit the
branches on the way down and got all
[ __ ] up dude I'm telling him but I
jumped and then
by the grace of Jesus Christ himself it
was just I'm M sore but it didn't rip
yeah my bladders gonna rip if I don't
copy right yeah PL my huge dick did ya
know I have had some friends who have
used better help my friends you mean me
yep and I've had some people hit me up
saying how great it was hmm better help
is basically an online therapy app for
lack of a better word yeah no it's no
hold up your get matched with a your own
licensed professional therapist yeah you
can start communicating in under 24
hours it's not crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional real
counseling done securely online there's
a broad range of expertise to help you
out whatever you need you've got a
counselor network okay it's available
world was a guy who speaks to a
professional I never thought it had any
value oh my god was I wrong it's
fantastic I agree it's the it's a sir
it's available to clients worldwide you
can log in your account anytime send a
message to your counselor it's also
affordable
yeah it crazy expensive like traditional
right counts are offline 25 bucks
financial aid is even available
no this isn't a tourist a lot of times
when you sit down with a for 45 minutes
in LA not here does it better help calm
slash fighter and join the over 500,000
people taking charge of their mental
health right now with the help of an
experienced professional fighter the kid
listeners you get ten percent off your
first month that better help calm slash
fighter get your brain right get your
brain right you know I feel good pissing
oh it's a nice feeling yeah it's a nice
view now it's a onesie in the new studio
so you want in the Earl I wouldn't think
yeah and he look at my dick and he goes
like this you got a dick on you huh and
I appreciate that
dude nothing makes me happier than
peeing in a sink yeah I don't know why
since college cuz it's naughty it's a
little naughty I feel like a Mongol or
some type in there ya know just poses
I'll get to those guys yeah I pee in the
sink hard
yeah you just I just you're now at the
water yes I feel like bad you know you
bad boy what you know what used to I got
it when in college and the dorms cuz
obviously there's one bathroom for the
whole floor but they gave us a sink
where you brush your teeth in the dorm
penis think of yeah every morning yeah
that morning piss and did think yeah my
roommate hated it but he's way smaller
saying there's that anything sometimes
urine can stink though you know yeah I
can but I don't care I pee in the sink
toilet feels good and people go don't do
that why dude I like it yeah I made my
mark
yeah is Lily not [ __ ] the thing that
I sometimes I rub my dong on the
doorknob so people have to tell you god
that's interesting why okay what else we
got you know people do that weird [ __ ]
do they really because I yeah there's a
weird life that I can't touch anything
I don't you rubbed your dick on the
handle and I I don't give a [ __ ] who
cares
it'll nos no that's no song like
guarantee no his song via biggest song
duh I listen to cowboy song yeah but uh
I love it I know you join an array yeah
you know it I love that suck your dick
oh you oh he's getting glory holes just
came out super gay okay nas ex just came
out on Twitter yesterday for the last
day of cry he didn't flat-out say that
he was gay or bisexual he just said to
listen to his song closer a little bit
he kind of made it pretty obvious cuz
then the next text at the tweet after
that he goes I tried to tell y'all and
in one of his videos
it shows the city there it is and then
that one of them is super rainbow okay
but also you look at a lot of outfits
it's like yeah no [ __ ] whatever [ __ ]
he's great
no yes I think it's cool now here's the
thing this guy put thank you for always
supporting me bro the guy goes just cuz
I'm gay don't mean I'm gay haha bro
please tell me tell you're you you're
gay as a joke
I'm gay as the joke yeah here's the
thing is being gay more except in
african-american culture really not
wrong
especially in rap name one white gay
name one gay rapper who's successful go
I've talked to some people who Tyler the
Creator they don't know though it's up
in the air oh well
did he come out easily flower boy it was
I think a year ago you told me not out
that he's gay I talked to some some some
gay gay I mean some I'm sorry it's some
black artists who are well known and all
of them will tell you that even come out
joking around about brown so so so or I
know a lot of poles forty percent of the
black popular african-american
population is conservative and the other
thirty percent is moderate and it's very
it's a very it's a the the population
was actually liberal and you know
socially liberal is actually much
smaller so yeah it's being gay is always
a liability for your black audience you
will lose you will lose your audience
but I feel like in today's culture with
the kids it's a nice big deal change but
as far as yeah I don't know man we'll
see it's changing but I don't give a
[ __ ] if he suck dick or suck titties I
could care less
music is music but I feel like in the in
the like hip-hop culture its frowned
upon way more get if you're if you're
dreaded and they talk about I want to
have talked where this a black artist
was talking about the fact that when
you're in hip-hop culture there's a lot
of pressure to be macho hard and all
those things especially when you come
from certain parts of the country
rightful if you're from South Central or
something you can't really it it's an
aggressive part of the world you know
you've got to be you got to put up a
front and appearances so percentage of
african-american homosexuals well
whatever I'll just throwing that in
there I'm gonna say it's three percent
typically three point seven and thirty
four percent is that saying thirty four
how many people are admitting to it how
do you do these things yeah you have to
actually take a survey and answer stuff
right oh yeah now what would but what
what's the percent what's the percentage
of whites same thing six the same thing
three percent yes oh really is it always
that low yeah you'll hear people say it
ten percent above it was not true at all
it's much much more than that I'd say
five percent maybe maybe tops still a
rarity it's still not up well it's not
the majority
then there guys I want to be gay like
yourself you know whatever and well
there's also guys who are married and in
the closet like yourself I want glory
holes was this those confusing trying no
it's that 58% that's not it
there's no way scroll up gentle air this
is the very top let me see the very top
that's not shale GBT gender ratio
no it's something's wrong with that yeah
oh it's where it's where gay people are
likely to live oh okay yeah
most live in liberal parts of the
country yeah I just feel like yeah if if
he was a white singer like Sam Sheridan
there's a bunch of gay boys Elton Chong
doesn't just say Sam surgeon not sure
that's it because we may have a friend
named Sam Smith yeah Sam Smith yes super
gay yeah nothing about it how about fact
we can sing his what a voice whoo what
else we got oh yeah I hope it hasn't
affected Korea no Donald Trump stood are
stepped in to North Korea this first
sitting president ever first sitting US
presidents ever stepped in there nice if
that if that Korean dictator died of
food he looks like he's gonna explode
have you heard his voice - he hasn't
actually another deep voice and you
respect it yeah let me hear it
let's see if it plays here with these
two let's go to the right this is the
[Applause]
who's in better better healthy think
they're both he's a king of that guy The
Crow they're both kings Trump's huge do
something boy yeah Trump's so out of
shape it's a big man that's Donald
Trump's I Instagram page
yeah 13.5 million followers interesting
that's cool I guess that he stepped over
North Korea huh
he might just a step on the right just
pull off a historic deal because he's a
guy who I'm gonna greens are worried
about he's getting reelected I think you
should be worried about him right
because if he is he's like oh he's not
[ __ ] around I mean Donald Trump is I
think that he realizes that the North
Koreans understand one thing and that's
a fist and if you guys want to [ __ ]
around
he's like oh boy yeah we'll light you up
but with Iran the Iran thing's little
difference also like posturing there's a
lot of posturing going on so so Bolton
so so John Bolton Michael no John Bolton
and and Mike Pompeo are both are both
hawks they call him hawk so that means
they they favor military action they're
neither one of them I don't think I've
done [ __ ] John Bolton who's the guy
who was really about the Iraq war and
really pushing it he was in the National
Guard he dodged the draft he's not of
course he's not a real soldier of course
so he never little work he never fought
and died he never fought and saw people
die but he's all about pushing people
into war but was it cool that Trump was
like they told me how many people are
gonna die and I was like nah we're not
gonna do it
yeah and that Donald Trump said John
Bolton is a hawk I disagree with him a
lot he's way too militaristic for me I
mean I like that so Donald Trump is not
the guy don't [ __ ] around with him at
the end of the day he doesn't agree with
Mike Pompeo and John Bolton I find it
very significant a lot of these guys who
pushed for the Iraq war and are really
hawkish on Iran have never really done a
day of fighting
maybe they avoided the draft in Vietnam
because they were in I think Mike Pompeo
was in the Air Force I'm not sure but
you know I don't respect those guys as
much as but the guys who've done time in
the military and have seen the horrors
of war they tend to a lot of you know
what becomes with it they tend to be a
lot more hesitant you know what
surprised me is no one really wants to
go to war do they like if you if like
guys who've never been to war do maybe
but even guys who are like 18 and 21
years old who Iran wants to go to war
they're walking on the streets of Iran
like you know me my brother where the
other day in Santa Monica they they
don't want to [ __ ] go to war right
they don't hate us but that is my and
it's the egos of the dictatorship that
make people [ __ ] kill
each other it's not good yeah and he
never served in the Gulf War I guess
look at this it's not good yeah he's
never employed the PDO so [ __ ] man
so these guys we ever go to war with
Iran ever been the theater of war so
he's good for the economy doesn't it war
well it's it's I think it's bad I think
it's bad in general you always want to
make it short make sure it's the last
[ __ ] resort and that's and I and I
think Trump was for the most part
against the Iraq war for most of his
career so you have to give that up what
else you guys got this hero teen I love
this you caught this to your girl that
was dangling from a window you just saw
some girl me around Turkey in Turkey
turkey watch the saw a girl playing
around he's like oh crap she's gonna
fall that's so scary it's also tough to
gauge where people are gonna fall yes I
know watch this guy the way he catches
her it's just in the nick of time boom
save and there's just one of those
things where your parents are so cute -
she's so cute it's like a [ __ ] man
where's the parents if you turn around
for once do rezaian the kid got up there
some kids climb that's horrible man look
where you saved her though they're
awesome God and you should say okay I
saw the footage later zoom [ __ ] cute
if it's terrifies me yeah that's
definitely not her what else she got
after that guy I just thought this was
kind of funny so this woman has issues
with her neighbor so she ended up
shooting into the neighbor's house and
also putting a fire by shauna - ow yeah
like oh gun yes and Connor on CCTV she
got caught on our own camera she didn't
want to give the police the footage but
dude is there anything worse than bad
neighbors though it'll ruin your flow
nice though this chick is crazy that's
her there yeah she has a gun in her hand
right now so watch she's about to go BAM
she shot me into the house look at her
looking smoking a cigarette did you just
stop on it side
there goes but even the gunshot was she
doing that for she's just pissed off I
guess they've always hated each other
and one day she just wanted to
come over and just do some warning shots
maybe but it's actually going into the
house so it's weird I mean that's that
shooting about a house it's a felony
yeah and then that's what threw a towel
[ __ ] oh shut it fire in there trying to
burn that house now
she's smart because that wouldn't catch
her house on fire I know it's because
there's a wooden fence that connects the
two well she's not a thoughtful person
probably knows what happened this lady
off the array obviously I do a lot of
time and then the reason why they found
is because people were people saw the
blaze so they call the fire department
then the police showed up showed up to
her place and wanted to see her camera
footage she said she doesn't want to
show it to him they eventually got it
anyways and it showed all of her I
showed her doing all those things
shooting and then trying to fire in the
place down
dumbass have you ever had any bad
neighbors yeah dude I argued no dude I
had one in Marina del Rey they were
older they're like 45 I remember other
than that apartment and you know I was
in a professional fight at times I need
my rest I'd have to go to training early
more and drive to Orange County
they'd have parties doing cocaine surely
five yeah and I'd knocked on the knock
like this they'd knocked back like [ __ ]
you all the time and it was exhausting
exhausting you had bad neighbors yeah
they didn't knew what happened with them
what did you do with them didn't you I
would talk to the guy knew who I was and
knew I was a professional fighter and he
was cool the life was [ __ ] crazy yeah
I had a really bad situation as in court
cop oh really yeah we're in Venice
really crazy there's nothing worse so I
knew he was a bad person I I resorted to
you snitched on them no I I I did some
stuff and like her not bad God he'd call
the cops I mean I had detectives come to
my house cuz I was I was he was really
he was terrorizing the neighborhood and
that's the wrong thing and did him I
went crazy and then I went to court and
everything she then he got into court
yep and he got arrested for elder abuse
turns out he had he we went I went in he
had he had his uncle
tied to a bed yep his little head of
water on the brain
he had all the
and everything labeled socks and then he
had for whatever reason it's so creepy
every doorknob was covered by a small
bag a small like sock like bag yep and
he was completely out of his mind and
the detective called me and said to me
you know view scary yeah but I was also
um I was going to war with him I was
going to war there's crazy stuff he has
picked he had he showed pictures in
court of me because I was I would go I
would I would I was trying to like him
to do so I did some [ __ ] yeah and I and
then the cop the arbitrator showed me
pictures and so the detective called me
and said hey um the detective called
first and said listen you know there's
been some things going on with a
neighbor you know I said I know I don't
know what's going on and then you know
the detective said she goes listen you
know she said you do know what's going
on and and I know you're a good guy also
in who you are because I was I and she
goes I don't want to be the guy I don't
want to come to your house I've seen how
these things escalate I have a feeling
that you're probably you know she said I
don't want to be I don't want to come to
your house and have to arrest you for
something you did that you have to live
with the rest of your life she knew she
the guy oh he got arrested and his
family members came down told me how
crazy he was I mean it was a very bad
thing and then he they lost the house
they sold a house family sold the house
the the uncle was put into elderly care
but I knew I knew this guy was a bad guy
and I took it under him I said this is
my I'm not gonna let this guy bully it
started with him stopping a woman my
neighbor and spitting on her car and
then taking her tire and throwing it on
her yeah and I was like not gonna do
that to me and he would wear his
military uniform he had been in the
military and he would wear a military
uniform and kind of try to try to
threaten people but I was like oh okay
go yeah but but so am I so we're like
okay here we go
here your HUD template - yeah I get I
can't stand a bully yeah and it's my
house and I get neighborhood I get crazy
well you know dude yeah you just
speaking of him with that uncle you know
the number one circular of all time was
actually a guy who worked in like old
people homes like both hospitals he
doesn't get a lot of fame but he was a
guy who he was like just
like an assistant to like old people
that were based in the hospital Hospice
homes and he was just killed like would
go they get access actually going and
just put like poison in their IVs and
they die they ask somebody killed 86
don't you serial killer in America just
Justi just that I got I got caught
because he was gay as [ __ ] and he his
boyfriends like given proms
so he started poisoning the boyfriend
and then he said it just was to remind
me of it is that an issue with the
neighbor
so he started poisoning the neighbor and
then it was like oh [ __ ] you try
poisoned me so they go back and they
accuse him then they go back and look at
all where he worked and like well during
the period when he was working here
forty people died the same way and they
go was he there he had access they go to
another hospital
forty people died there st. period so
they then they yeah he got off on
killing crazy right
he killed some people like pelo
suffocation other in just old people so
no one really checked in they're like
well he's just old past any like you I
passed away well it's changed his
catheter it's so terrible and some
people he killed by putting the extra
big catheters in it's terrible person
yeah just got off on some people get off
on kill you and so you can tell when
somebody's bad I I just knew this have a
good right yeah I knew I knew for a lot
of reasons I'm being and it's scary
though when you know stone who's like
that scary like oh [ __ ] it was the most
stressful time for me there's nothing
more stressful than a bad Nia I was in a
war especially owned the place or if you
like when I had a bad neighbor house
renting but I have a ton of money at the
time so it's like I can't go anywhere
they're not going anywhere this is awful
yeah what else to get can ask what
ethnicity your neighbors were white your
it's a white interesting oh yeah white
it's always the white guy this story was
really cool I thought it was gonna be
real but some people decide to be fake
for sure this is fake Chan but in the
beginning it was great out of Brian when
I saw and Rogan posted this I clicked on
it well that's a fake story me at all
when you look at the picture you can
tell it's pretty much fake but I wanted
it to be real look at that bad no but
just read the story bright yeah tell me
worried that's the guy so whole and this
guy says a bear attacked him broke his
back
put him in the den to eat later thirty
days go by
they found him no food no food for 30
days and and buy a beer and broke his
back that be fake sir that would be fake
there were some experts that talked
about if it if it's possible that bears
sometimes do store their food and a
legate let it rot and then they eat it
later and then but the figure the guy
would have to literally he could survive
without food for a month or like three
weeks or something like that 21 days
somebody yeah but he would need water
and one way he would get water and also
minerals and whatever nutrients from the
water is icicles if that's [ __ ] up
yeah I mean what happened to him I guess
is just they just faked this somehow
well that's a that's not a real person
oh it's not well it'd be fake okay all
of its fake yeah it's all fake cuz that
looks I don't know if this is a if he is
a real person or no - no well that's a
debt or that's a real army that's
a--that's a real court or maybe it looks
like him and they just said it was in
that's deaf I don't know that's right
when I saw it right I saw the headline
oh that's fake his [ __ ] yeah
oh dude soand did send me a picture or
I'm sorry Instagram story with her hey
Brian was definitely off on the beer one
but this one's real it's a dude on the
bike with a tiger
oh dude do you know what to talk about
yes no I thought you saying that guy
that told me you didn't see this oh my
god this is so [ __ ] scoot oh yeah oh
yes let me see it doesn't get to him
yeah there it is there the first one
yeah did so he's riding his bike across
across this buses yes this is it we're
not fast that thing is where is this
dude that's you look like food to a
tiger wait what was this I was in India
Tigers are in India that was a real one
oh yeah dude was looking at me ask that
500-pound tigress you [ __ ] kidding me
Tigers are scary Lee this thing dude
it does look more real it is really is
real to me I it's possible that it's not
more to me was like dude this one's real
the bear one you guys were watching us
fake yeah not again they might be
bullshitting but I think that's real
that looks like a tiger was if they were
on paper would they be dead it looks
like a tiger saw it was like I'm gonna
take this guy down Mac could there be
any thing oh that a [ __ ] tiger yeah
cuz usually you can tell somebody else a
fake but now yeah a lot of them are not
saying that James all right what else we
got Wow this one I wish I had more
details on it but okay so Scooter Braun
who is the manager of like ariana grande
and Justin Bieber Demi Lovato a little
Dickie all those people Taylor Swift's
original record company big machine I
guess that was her former company but
they owned all of her masters and then
Scooter Braun apparently bought that all
of her masters and then she didn't have
any idea about it
so apparently her dad is in control of
her career so he was supposed to know
about it but she heard about it through
just looking online so she has no
ownership of any of the music that she
had before on that label which is Hughes
I'm sorry what so scooter Braun's a bad
guy because her dad sold him the master
she's saying that because he wants to
money he's been bullying her before and
he's did it on purpose like without
telling her at least tell her beforehand
so she can know why isn't it further I
mean listen it's it sucks for music okay
shitty dad sell to scrap yeah I'll buy
your music protect your music she would
have if she knew like this all happened
under her dad's a bad guy basically or
sneak it could be that or or me nobody
found a way to do this without letting
it here's the thing as an artist that is
horrific hold on as an artist there's
nothing worse for her I'm sure
Oh ninny or masters and you're Taylor
Swift that's great you're [ __ ] man so
to make all your money but also don't
have to my [ __ ] go back so justin bieber
calls out taylor swift for crossing a
line and Scooter Braun controversy
there's a lot of different slurries are
taking sides on this to Iggy Azalea and
Demi Lovato other artists a lot of
people are saying like that you
shouldn't take her that's her life's
work so at least she has to be involved
in the that's giving raising so can she
sue for that or I don't know though
that's the thing if it's a legal
transaction but here's the thing but if
her dad if it was a legal transaction
without her knowing you could sue in the
court of law
right unless she gave had much unless
she gave the power of attorney to her
father to sell this well her because her
father might have void the contract
without letting her know that this
transition happened right yeah she might
be alright it's also Taylor Swift mrs.
Bush use a bronze shitty move but also
tight move you're making a lot of money
it does look like her dad is the one
that didn't tell her but yeah for the
whole scooter for a company to take your
masters that's still a shady move right
it's gotta be a shaking you bring up sky
yeah can you bring up scooter bronze why
for a second all right there wait yeah
now right there down there there's a I
want to just I think I know
Scooter Braun is three hundred million
dollars yeah he's just being a
businessman though yeah yeah blame it
listen for Taylor Swift it's awful but
the dad's the [ __ ] in this dupe
someone came up to me was that K man you
wanna buy Taylor Swift's Masters for
three hundred million I had three and
really you serious yeah what'd you do
oh I'm her manager I'm her father you
were given the opportunity to own your
masters you passed interesting the man
you're so grossed out by believed in you
more than you believe in yourself your
dad is a shareholder and was notified
and Borchetta personally told you before
this came out so no you didn't find out
what the world and girl who you talking
about bullying the world has watched you
collect and dropped friends like wilted
flowers
husband is anything but a bully he spent
his life standing up for people and
causes he believes it and I'm kind of
I'm kind of with this great on that easy
to see that the point is she said this
out was to get people to bully him you
were surprised you were supposed to be a
role model but continued to model bully
content model bullying he's a manager
not God he cannot control the actions of
other human human humans even once he
manages don't blame him because Kim
caught you in a lie
that's Jairus you know about this now
I'll fill you in on this it's
embarrassing I know but adults own up to
their mistakes we learn and grow from
them we don't divert blame and blur the
lines of reality to suit your our needs
what you haven't seen is what happens
behind closed doors when he has
supported and stood up for you when he
has challenged his clients to be kind or
be quiet when he has reached an out
reached an olive branch out to you on
numerous occasions listen I like that
she's brown fin Brunner was so excited
to work and build with you how
embarrassing this temper tantrum is
because you didn't get your own way he
believes in and supports you I sincerely
hope you can learn to love and believe
in yourself the way my husband does
lastly if you think he can control his
clients please control your fans leave
our personal life and kids out of this
you don't understand yet what line that
crosses but one day you will and I hope
you have the dignity class and kind of
stay out of this you only have an open
discussion tumblr can't fix it's a phone
call again
hey so Kanye released a song and asked
Taylor Swift if is OK to release it he
releases it she comes out on social
medias like I had no idea he didn't okay
it would be and then Kim filmed Kanye
calling Taylor & Canas hates well you
know I put you in the song and I just
want to get your Clint she goes yeah no
problem thank you yeah no problem
Kim film that and then when it's song
came out Taylor's all this is [ __ ]
no one gave me a heads up and Kim my
arms I'm sorry this if that's the case
and that's pretty much the Sun burning
here from a few people friends who've
dinner that she's a bit of a nightmare
yeah a lot of people don't like Telos
not for her she always makes herself the
victim in
situations like this with the situation
you were talking about is because Kanye
said said in his song I made this [ __ ]
famous and in the video she says oh it's
fine because it's like a compliment to
me and it was going back to when Kanye
interrupted her speech at the VMAs then
we said Beyonce should have won and he
goes hates well you know I'm doing this
song
hopefully it's cool she went yeah no
problem yeah I have no problem at all
what did she say she didn't know he's
gonna say I made this [ __ ] famous no no
he told her the lyric
oh no she the whole full closure yeah
and then Kim films it just you know saw
that for the records and then in Taylor
goes off here's your thing Taylor has a
insane fan base so she's like six her
fans on them she did blast this out
saying he was a bully well you know what
here's the problem that the truth will
eventually come out like aliens and air
51 people can't hold a secret and so the
truth will come out and with Taylor not
now you're [ __ ] with the Biebs your
[ __ ] he works with a lot of powerful
people in music so yeah so any on the
book the beep stood up for scooter -
yeah yeah I think Biebs it was nice
about it - it was really nice about it I
loved it but you know there was a
well-written [ __ ] response hell yeah
it was a well written dad I wish they
would write look good for you Danna that
girls down for her man I love the name
scooter by the way there was a post that
um Kanye Kanye and uh Bieber and
whatever someone else did that was kind
of like messed up - Taylor I don't
remember what it was but there was a
thing when they all kind of ganged up
against also Taylor Bieber apologized
and I was young then yeah also she's a
[ __ ] what else you got - that's all the
good stuff yeah there's nothing really
odd this one all right good stories out
of the week news nah man I went to a
wedding you nights [ __ ] did shows and
Brea dude most of my good stories I
can't say on hair but it was fun well
we've done it again first one the new
studio B and this thing's gonna be done
there put loving our new student when
the new it's and just like it's so many
more at K yeah we had a lot of room here
I'd like him so much room for activities
we gotta suck glory hole over there huh
with XX player we need a jujitsu mat I
need a boxing rings Mike
you get all our stuff up but by next
week this place even [ __ ] rose and
we're all in it dude that's it buddy
cool man gonna be man oh I'm glad you
asked because next week I'm in
Cincinnati have you been there hold on
funnybone Cincinnati Ohio next week
Friday Saturday there no that's that's
in 12 days buddy yeah next week well
it's no it's 12 days from now buddy so
it's two weeks oh crap it is two weeks
from now yeah come on this is July
fourth weekend first rehearsal Thursday
is July fourth yeah 50 6 7 8 9 12
that'd be next week dudes well it's 12
days yeah not this week next week okay
that's what I said next week how'd that
make sense to you I hope that worries me
because I'll be in spec an no hold on
then that make sense yeah it doesn't
make sense I said this week well you
know next weekend I thought Brown was
saying thank you for this again listen
[ __ ] working via what you guys [ __ ]
me this is the July 4th weekend next
weekend oh it's the phone working
yeah the 12th through the 13th I'm in
Cincinnati Ohio bunny bone I'm in
spending in Washington you sure are in
smoking with my favorite spots and then
after that I'm in Indianapolis good
thing those are so far away so it's not
the same market anyway but I'm in the
appleís way to go Justin July 18th
through the 20th and then tickets almost
sold out in Nashville already natural
zany's August 1st through the 3rd and
then Portland just got announced good
shakes now next week you [ __ ] so spike
and Cincinnati
spec and Washington in the 11 12 and 13
be next weekend
dude I'm uh punching your death 11 days
next weekend you [ __ ] and [ __ ] ass
what is the what's the club there though
it's just a comedy look funny bone with
a funny bone and then Spokane comedy
club down one all the Spokane comedy
club that's where I'm at I think that's
about my club go back to that and I'll
be in San Francisco cobbs this is my
20th obviate cobbs San Francisco on my
favorite place yeah then you're in
Cincinnati in October do see if I can
make that y'all look at the club yeah
yeah let me see that Club that's where
it says Bryan Callen ABC Matty I'm
totally do it - great why don't I have
HBO a MADtv
your [ __ ] way to advertise me okay
it's weird what can you do do it's a
great club that I promise dude look at
my arm you'll love that man yeah you
look you look young in that dude
um Brennan what I'm serious don't say
stuff like that all right you look young
Thanks
all right dude we're out I'm Dominic
[ __ ] next week dudes since tonight
all right and you're in Cincinnati in
the NRA Indianapolis are not too close
to each other to our 's that's all right
two hours there you know your geography
dudes mine hey Duke hey it sucked on hey
Indianapolis you guys you [ __ ] better
have a marquee advertising the Brennan
shops there otherwise we're gonna purl
outside okay you better for real and put
a glory hole in my hotel room yeah those
are my demands and red M&Ms and rhymes
all right that's it dude congrats from
their studio
yes the fine kid we're out